smart go ahead let's let's try okay so
basically it's about Free Will and good
and evil Concepts Free Will and what
again Free Will and uh good and evil
Concepts oh yeah yeah yeah that's a very
good question it's gonna be I don't know
if I can answer in two minutes but let's
see what the gist of your question is I
may have to do a series on but go ahead
Yeah so
basically uh if God knows everything why
did he create Satan e like why did he
create Satan as evil but at the same
time you might say that in order to have
a free will you need both good and evil
but God himself is good and he has Free
Will and he's not evil no God is Not Who
said he had free
will oh really no God the Bible says God
because he has a nature that's
unchangeable he cannot do everything and
he cannot be evil and he cannot sin
where'd you get he got free will I
mean uh I'm but I think in Christianity
can I say can I continue no but I'm
you're you're saying Christianity God
cannot do everything so don't
misrepresent Christianity that's not
what we believe okay no it's because I
thought if God can create the universe
and like the like the black holes and
space and everything he surely has free
will that's my thoughts what is that
what what does that got to do with free
will that God because he's Almighty can
create a
creation but that doesn't mean that
means he's free to oppose his nature
you're confusing two issues
if he has the ability to create then
yeah he can choose to exercise that
ability but you're defining Free Will
meaning that he has the power to act
contrarily to his nature to go against
his nature no the Bible doesn't say
that's what free will is in reference to
God because you see how you defined it
now you change the definition you went
to that God has the freedom to create or
not to create yes that's true but you're
defining it in terms of Good and Evil
God does not have the freedom to do evil
see that's where you're misde the term
Free Will so you use two different
definitions of Free Will and Confused
yourself are you asking me is God free
to act upon his attributes such as the
attribute of power and then exercise
that power to create or choose not to
create yeah he's free to do that but
he's not free to go against his nature
you confuse two issues so which issue
you want me to
address uh yeah think got complicated
really quick uh yes that's what I said
yeah I I I thought in I thought that the
Christian God has maybe the Muslim God
can not the Christian God because your
God Allah you don't even know what his
nature is that that's why he can be
called The Arrogant proud
one the best of all deceivers because
you have no idea what his nature is
whereas in the god of the Bible Hebrews
61718 it says it's impossible for him to
lie it's not possible you can't do it or
in 2 Timothy 2:13 says he cannot deny
himself not possible cannot James 1:13
he cannot be tempted so our God cannot
just do everything your God no one knows
about him he can do what he wants it
seems he can be a liar he can be proud
but we're not told he can be humble
that's the problem with you not with
me okay so um I guess the other question
is what why did uh if God knows
everything let's see let's kind of
rephrase it if God if God knows
everything he would have known that
Satan would Rebel right like before time
why would he like allow it you know yeah
I that's a question that is plague
theologians and philosophers for
centuries and everyone comes up with a
way of trying to articulate it so
whatever I tell you it's just one
opinion among many because we know
number one first of all let's start with
facts when I say facts that we believe
our facts if an atheist doesn't even
believe in God fact God exists fact he
created the universe fact in this
universe there are Spirit creatures and
also human beings fact Spirit creatures
and human beings have rebelled and
caused Great Havoc disaster chaos and
misery and pain okay now then the
question comes down to all right God
created these Spirit beings and these
human beings and even animals who
inflict harm even animals unfortunately
inflict harm on one another even insects
and so on did God know that well if he's
all knowing then surely he knows that
but now the question is
this is now where it's going to get deep
and don't ascribe any view to me I'm
just telling you the range of options
where people have wrestled with this
question and look to the Bible if you're
a Christian you look to the Bible if
you're a Muslim you look to the Quran
and Sunnah and the Quran and Sunnah is
already settled for you if you're a
Sunni you know the answer to this right
no not really I'm like I'm open to
anything at this point so well if you go
to Sunni Islam the Quran and Sunnah not
sh they have different Traditions Allah
predestined all the evil and misery it
was his will is and
does not mean he knew you're going to do
it no no Muhammad said that the destiny
of a child whether he was created for
Paradise or Hell will overtake him at
some point in his life because Allah has
already created the person for hell or
for Jenna so he was a very hyper what we
call fatalist a hyper calvinist so let's
put that aside coming to scripture there
are people say God did know that that
when he created Satan and human beings
that they would freely Rebel but he
still wanted a world in which these
creatures exist and they would Rebel
because in spite of their Rebellion the
world he created would bring about the
greatest number of human beings who
would choose to believe in him and enjoy
him and reign with him that's one
question because he wanted a world to
exist of creatures who could make
choices so they could experience his
love and dwell in his presence and he
knew that this is the best and most
Ideal World to create to get the most
amount of people people to freely
believe in him and be saved that's one
one view possibility yeah yes the other
View and there are Christians who
believe this Believe It or Not There are
Christians who believe this so take it
up with them I'm just telling you and
they will quote verses because the
Bible's written such a way whatever you
want to find you'll find there just like
the Muslim will find whatever he wants
in the Quran and the Sunnah that's how
these books are written you can
intercept it anyway right yes and
there's one view that says this there's
one view that says this
it says that God knows
all
possibilities and all actualities he
knows everything that can possibly take
place but the future doesn't exist in
reality and because it doesn't exist in
reality God knows everything that can
possibly happen in the future but what
actually takes place he does not know
until it occurs this is called open
theism
that's a view among Christians that's
another view that's how they try to
reconcile why would God create a world
in which you have so much fness and evil
they'll say because God is an infinite
mind and he knows every
possible thing a creature can do but
until the creature does it it's not a
reality so there's no way for it for him
to know it because it doesn't exist
because in this view God didn't create
the future God created creation and lets
the future unfold and he oversees what
will take place and he's sustaining the
future as it takes place but he's not
the one who ordained the future to take
place and created it that's one view
that's open theism now many people don't
like that view they reject it I
understand yeah those are the two views
but then you have the view that's
similar to Sunni Islam it's the
calvinist view that God has created all
reality present past and future time and
he's created everything that takes place
in creation so he knows the future
because he's already decreed what the
future will be like so you make choices
but those choices were already ordained
by God for you to make and then they'll
tell you he doesn't make you do it you
do it but he decreed that you'll do it
so that at the end of the day it becomes
a mystery of
paradox um which one do you believe in
I'm just curious I don't believe that
God has created you to do evil I would
actually go with the first view that God
created the world which he knows that
creatures would sin but nonetheless this
was the optimum Ideal World for him to
create because this is the world that
will great get the most amount of people
to be saved so he didn't create Satan
and de cre Satan would Rebel he knew
he'd Rebel but created him nonetheless
because this is the only world of all
the worlds he could create that would
bring about the most number of creatures
turning to him to be saved any other
world would bring a less amount of of
people for
salvation uh yeah I mean maybe but uh so
God could have chosen not to create but
obviously he wanted to create so now we
have to deal with the fact that he did
create because he didn't have to create
but he wanted to create because uh we
have you know a lot of planets a lot of
galaxies if if it's just about sheer
numbers you know he could have uh done
it in a different way if it's about
numbers now to make that arrogant claim
means that you have the mind of God and
know he could have how do you know that
I I well I don't know of course but I'm
saying maybe maybe but how would you
know it's a maybe do you have his mind
to know all possible worlds and all
possible realities and all possible
creations and which creation is most
ideal that's an arrogant statement s
like you think I'm sure he does right
yeah but I'm saying if this is the world
he created that means this is the best
world because any other world would not
bring about the most number of people
who would get saved so you're actually
contradicting the point I'm making
you're saying no he could have created a
world how do you know that no I'm saying
uh we don't know anything I'm just I'm
just saying that's why Ah that's my
point so you may not like any of the
options but you're stuck with having to
wrestle with the fact you exist I exist
the world exists evil exists so either
there is no God and this was just an
explosion and the universe expanded in
such a way without any intelligent mind
guiding it that created all these
complex life forms so that to talk about
evil is silly because there's no such
thing as evil it's only chemical
reactions that's atheism or you're a
theist that believes there is a Creator
God and he's responsible for his
creation so now we have to wrestle why
this creation and not
another yeah fair fair I mean it it can
be a mix mixture of both you know like
of the chemicals and the evil and good
you know yeah but the if we believe God
created the world initially good no
defects that means these chemical
reactions are not working timately
because our minds our brains our nerves
have been damaged because of the evil
brought into the World by Satan and
Humanity that's the Biblical teaching
that evil Rebellion has brought damage
to the world because when God created it
he created it good so the way the brain
of Adam functioned before he rebelled
and was punished didn't function the way
our brains are doing so now